lo ng lanthier d'ailleurs qu'est basé en
martinique depuis trois ans maintenant
se focalise sur des projets à
l'international avec des échanges de
bonnes pratiques
on considère que les changes la
diversité culturelle sont des valeurs
ajoutées et sont des plus values pour le
territoire martiniquais et les antilles
et la caraïbe en général donc nous
organisons régulièrement des séminaires
des formations des ateliers
sensibilisation toujours pratiquement
toujours en tout cas en collaboration en
partenariat avec d'autres associations
d'autres ong européennes et
internationales
pourquoi raphaël concept donc là c'est
un projet punch à un projet dont
l'europe pour les citoyens toujours
internationale et pourquoi est ce qu'on
a choisi raphaël concept et louise
renard c'est pour son action de
valorisation du patrimoine qu'on trouve
extrêmement intéressant on a déjà
travaillé avec elle sur un autre projet
lié au tourisme responsable et elle nous
a totalement convaincu par son énergie
son dynamisme son envie de bien faire et
on pense que ça apporte sa participation
peut apporter beaucoup et à la
martinique et à son entreprise alors des
projets on a toujours plein plein plein
la suite à l'audience on vient
d'accueillir par exemple une trentaine
de
participants de 14 pays différents
européen sur la thématique du
volontariat européen puisque on permet
également à des jeunes martiniquais de
partir en volontariat se former c'est
l'équivalent du service civique mais
dans une association à l'étranger par
exemple donc on a bientôt des départs de
jeunes à suivre au portugal en grèce en
finlande